le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous présente lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais les trophées de
l'accessibilité sont des récompenses
décernées au niveau national à
l'initiative du concours national pour
toutes les régions de france soucieuse
de l'égalité des droits et des chances
de la participation et la citoyenneté
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans ce cadre des trophées de
l'accessibilité de 2015 le département a
déposé deux candidatures une dans la
catégorie accessibilité cadre de vie
bâti voirie et transport pour son action
au collège du tampon et une deuxième
dans la catégorie accessibilité
inclusion mixité et vivre ensemble
travail loisirs sports et culture qui
bénéficient de ces trophées de
l'accessibilité
on en parle tout de suite d'un lien
social
les trophées de l'accessibilité ont été
créé pour récompenser et promouvoir des
démarches des initiatives des
innovations des réalisations exemplaires
ayant pour effet des changements de
comportement et de culture en matière
d'accessibilité pour tous le département
est lauréat de deux trophées de
l'accessibilité
le premier étant pour l'artothèque de la
réunion pour une ouverture novatrices à
la culture avec les cafés de la rto le
deuxième trophée concerne son deuxième
collège neuf du 12e au tampon pour sa
classe ulis unité localisée pour
l'inclusion scolaire mais également pour
l'ump
l'institut médico pédagogique de bel air
à saint louis et liêm pro institut
médico-professionnel de trois mares ou
deux salles ont été dédiés le collège du
12e a été le premier bâtiment répondant
aux nouvelles normes
il a permis une réelle prise de
conscience des nouvelles méthodes et des
réflexes à avoir
florian dijoux à 14 ans et nous explique
ses divers handicaps et ce qu'il aime
dans ce collège
naissances lâche pas me représenter se
passer le temps jusqu'au yaws et un truc
de dire lité dans ce piège il ya deux
classes particulières du lys et de
l'adapei et ce qui est bien c'est que
l'eau qu'il a été conçu spécialement
pour nous si les preuves sont
sympathiques
les avs auxiliaires de vie sociale
apporte beaucoup d' aide aux enfants en
situation de handicap non indiqua que
mon peuvent dépasser facilement ça
m'épuise grâce aux avs ils peuvent pas
porter mon sac
du coup ça me fatigue mois pour marcher
j'ai pas lu mon post l'infirmerie que
des fois je peux utiliser l'ascenseur sa
8e point de l'escalier pour monter
jusqu'au troisième étage avant
j'ai dit fatigué il touche pas une seule
10 pour travailler je n'accuserai
préserver on est bien en face d'eux il
faut y a des abdos ce qui va nous aider
pour les devoirs pour la cantine pour
les pourrait écrire
j'attire tempe plus ferme eux de voir
qu'est-ce que florian m plus
particulièrement dans ce collège
quand même plein de copains avoir des
amis corinne rouch au fait partie des
avs qui suivent florian ici au collège
du 12e nous avons une classe ulis tfm
troubles des fonctions moteur
l'avantagent dans une classe ulis par
rapport à une classe classique c'est que
chaque élève peuvent être suivis par une
as hb ou un as hb l'avait sachets des
accompagnateurs des élèves en situation
de handicap
florian est un enfant qui aime beaucoup
être encadrées en ulis qui a besoin de
ça pour être sécurisé pour se sentir
valorisé au niveau de ces notes et des
très content qu'on soit la police pour
l'aider
la construction de ce collège a
bénéficié de la part du département de
beaucoup d'attention
frédéric thomas nous en dévoile une
partie c'est une opération de longue
haleine qui a vu la concrétisation avec
la livraison des travaux du collège en
août 2013 et des équipements sportifs
l'année suivante donc une opération qui
a coûté
à peu près 20 millions d'euros lé donc
un investissement investissements
importants de la part de la collectivité
l'enjeu de cette opération était double
pour le département d'abord livré son
premier collège neuf totalement
accessible aux handicapés
conformément à la loi handicap de 2005
donc accessible à l'ensemble des
handicapés que ça soit cognitif auditif
visuel ou moteur le deuxième enjeu était
d'intégrer deux unités d'enseignement
spécialisé dont une unité de type ulysse
type 4 dédié aux troubles des fonctions
motrices que le projet pourrait
concernant les deux sections
d'enseignement spécialisé a consisté
donc en cours de travaux en concertation
notamment avec l'architecte les bureaux
d'étude et les entreprises d'aménager
les deux structures en rez-de-chaussée
du bâtiment pour leur offrir un meilleur
cadre de vie cadre du vix qui permettra
effectivement de un épanouissement et
une inclusion de qualité de ses élèves
toutes ces actions ont permis de créer
un bien-être pour ces élèves en
situation de handicap en les sortant de
leur isolement
tout en permettant un changement de
regard et l'ouverture d'esprit des
enfants valides
cette édition s'inscrit pleinement dans
les dix ans de la loi du 11 février 2005
pour l'égalité des droits et des chances
la participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées
le conseil départemental en charge
notamment de ce public a mis en place
des réalisations exemplaires
s'inscrivant dans la durée et permettant
concrètement d'améliorer l'autonomie de
tous dans la vie citoyenne pour le
conseil départemental
ces deux distinctions récompensent le
travail d'une équipe avec pour objectif
de poursuivre ses initiatives
demain devront pour tous afin que
personne ne soit exclu
le conseil départemental de la réunion
vous a présenté lien social
le conseil départemental aux côtés des
réunionnais